simplicity of the rapid grant that's
what I think it's so easy to play course
the talents extraordinary with Toby
[Applause]
why did janitor better stay ready with
Eckstrom Reb
let's go prove me wrong this is what
they got to do just they want to get
this game
large realize as great as they are as
ball players such as kids like he did it
on purpose he wants to show the home
folks
NDSU only one out of seven for the feel
of this app is one of seven go to the
got the basket Berra with the post up
he's good inside two grand show
alongside game yes what do you want
coach handle things in the corner here
for the Blue Devils touch he'll be
already good this patient late the shot
glue trap walked his own takes away your
individual ability this particulars on
there you go cybus one and to go inside
that with this lineup I think some sort
of attacker post up
hey pull pull it down and Sian tines the
game at 34
there's gold wire that played his game
and we made one the other night he only
made two on the season out of 23
attempts
Williamson power Jones high passes the
shot from the corner
Simon traffic there you go then
impatient in attacking wasted a lot of
time
end of sentence Williamson driving out
taco as the basket cows Steve on your
shoulder big time delivery kids man this
was a what all won in the end with two
guys with four fouls it wasn't a dunk on
taco but deliver and it was his best
saying this guy right here all night
when his team has needed him well they
helped so well on defense they make you
shoot the ball from the perimeter
Luke has to be able to knock down shots
and of course hit the ball inside half
as ion that's the power game the big
fella a little bit large
pretty impressive after crashing to the
floor hitting two free throws getting on
to it
[Applause]
over 14 hormuz out of position and was
holding our design once he got beat
Wilkins really made that play
ize it at 30 in one moves right then
come back down nice tie by bear with
that size able to get free off the
screen had a good look at it they're not
hitting her shots
hold on Simon Jacques and took his back
in front by walk six the largest lead of
the game by Virginia Tech and as Jones
[Applause]
how high can you go put this I thought
that was going out of bounds if they
don't put William sit on the black
tell them we'll have time that's where
you got a dominate big fella standing
still and though post-up took off the
fifth year senior and that explosive
movement but on their timing of ball
reversal shorts did Bobby take it inside
there
I say so here we need to spam
he's doing that against a a very strong
big guy hypnic war